[Music]
can you watch a full five minute video
in 144p
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
when can we get some mkbhd merch well
okay so you may have noticed this custom
mkbhd edition
circuit design shirt that i've worn in
the past couple videos
this you can now get on sale right now
it is a limited edition for two weeks so
if you want to get it you should hop on
that the link is of course below it's
soft it's comfortable
wears well there's actually a couple
different colors available and it ships
internationally a lot of people forget i
actually have done two
shirts on on teespring in the past and i
think the goal with these is to make
something that you can wear
and people don't ask like what is that
you know you can wear it anywhere and
it's just kind of a cool design that
happens to have the logo incorporated
somewhere and i think we pulled that off
so yeah this design with the white
circuits now available in a couple
different dark colored shirts and this
design actually has its roots and
something else you'll see very soon but
until then it's available right now let
me know what you think how do you feel
after winning love day so that was
really fun so if for those of you who
don't know that 90 second video i did
with the tesla and the sort of an ad the
contest entry that we made that ended up
winning and it was really cool it got
shown on stage at the event all the
employees got to watch it live i saw the
reaction because i was there too it was
just really cool i think with shooting
that video a lot was learned like
obviously you can make a gadget review
of a phone or something like that with
one person because it's just me and my
camera but with a car video it's
physically impossible to make that with
one person so it ended up being a
four-person team of us you know one
person's driving one person's driving
another car in front one person's
hanging out the back with the camera on
a gimbal there's a lot going on and
that's the first time we actually did
those sort of moving car shots at
different angles it took us two days of
shooting and then the rest of it was
just editing and condensing it to 90
seconds which is yes why the weather
changed between different scenes in the
video and yes that's also why many of
you noticed the colors of the bags in
the front trunk also changed it's
because they're not the same bags but i
would definitely say the amount we
learned both in the editing trying to
cut something down into really short and
in the shooting trying to shoot car
videos you know getting roads and
getting all the different angles and
stuff uh will definitely be helpful as a
foray into future car videos because
there's more car tech out there and
we'll be covering more of that the other
videos that won second and third place
were extremely well produced i thought
the second place one the spaceships for
earth one could literally be a tv ad it
was really well done i'll link those
below also if you want to watch them
because they're really good also fun
fact this is the first time elon musk
ever uh tweeted at me ever mentioned my
handle he had to go out of his way to
find it because it wasn't i wasn't in
the conversation so thanks did you ever
get offers from media companies to work
for them if yes name them okay well yeah
i'm i'm not going to name them but yes i
have i remember specifically one when i
was in college where i was invited to a
certain media companies hq you've
probably heard of them they needed a tv
tech correspondent to be on tv all the
time talking about tech they needed
someone kind of young someone pretty
knowledgeable someone who's about to
graduate and i kind of fit that role and
i was 100 not interested i mean it was
an honor that they considered me and
that they brought me in to talk about it
but the whole like scripted tv story
after story
the whole live thing is is not really
what i'm into obviously i'm doing this
on youtube for reasons because this
format suits the way i want to talk
about things and the whole other thing
about like who's paying you versus what
you can and can't talk about that's also
weird too so bottom line i really do
like being independent and just using
this youtube platform to talk about
whatever i want why does samsung have
serious issues concealing their future
products than its competitors and and
why does it have too many leaks too okay
so basically it's 2017
everything leaks i've kind of said this
before and the reason behind that a lot
of people don't really realize
why things leak or how they leak but
supply chains from these companies like
samsung or like apple or like any of
these companies who you see their
products before they get announced it's
because they're huge there are so many
different steps in the chain between the
time it gets designed and then it gets
manufactured and then it gets approved
and then it gets made all these
different steps with thousands of people
if just one of them releases or leaks
something a little bit it can be really
hard to track and really hard to punish
and also really hard to stop there's all
these really interesting articles and
posts about how like people will will
try to pay foxconn factory workers who
are working on iphones
massive amounts of money for that
information because they don't make that
much money it can be super tempting if
you work in that factory and someone
offers you a year's wage to show them
what the front panel of the iphone looks
like and then you get fired but so what
you have a year's wage now so yeah
bottom line these companies are really
big and they try to make sure people
don't get the information about their
phone and it's all secretive and
obviously you're not allowed to talk
about it but stuff seems to slip through
the cracks every now and then and census
2017 it just gets amplified second
what's on video when okay so the first
what's on video for those of you who are
new was the studio tour of casey neistat
we shot that in the city that was a
really fun episode number one my
intention for the series is for it to be
roughly three or four times a year which
means if it's a really really big well
thought out production it's once every
three or four months so that's kind of
the rate we're looking at so we're
looking at the next episode now and
we're trying to make it as awesome as
possible but yeah that's why you don't
really see one every week because that
would be really hard let's talk about
the snake snake what i don't
i don't know what you're uh
i don't really know what you're talking
about actually no just kidding these
snakes so these guys uh these are little
ball pythons i see these because there's
another one back there but our neighbors
the studio have a couple of them and so
you may see them make random appearances
and videos sometimes also this guy's an
instagram you should follow him i'll
link it below what do you think about
apple making self-driving cars okay so
i've actually seen and heard this rumor
a bit but what's interesting is uh in
the past couple weeks i've seen
these sorts of cars floating around the
new york city new jersey area i've taken
pictures of them myself so i know
they're like out there i've seen them in
new york and i've seen them like on the
jersey turnpike and it says apple maps
on the side of the car like i get that
but it's very clearly not just apple
maps there are way too many sensors on
the back and on the top and all this
measurement tools
it just kind of seems to me like a
self-driving car project if i'm looking
at it from afar and it doesn't say maps
on it but they might just kind of be
disguising it as maps but the real
question here is is apple actually gonna
make a car
i don't think they have to make a car to
make a self-driving car project if you
look at what tesla's doing a lot of that
actually half of that
is the software behind making a car
drive itself tesla's half a car company
and half a software company between like
making all the cameras talk to each
other and all the radar and all the
sonar making all those sensors make the
car self-aware enough to drive itself
and avoid obstacles apple
they're also a software company so i
feel like they'll do a ton of research
and a ton of measurement and whatever
else they're doing with those cars
undercover to try to make their best
possible self-driving car software
safety is number one convenience also
very important but yeah apple could make
a self-driving car project and never
actually make a car as a fellow model s
owner i'm curious about the features
you'd like to see in future software
hardware updates well contrary to
popular belief the software on the tesla
is not perfect in fact one of the most
popular things or most common things
i've wanted to see is spotify in the
music player it's been like a long time
coming still isn't there do you think
the pixel 2 without a three and a half
millimeter jack is the right way to go
after the pixel teased apple during its
debut okay so that is going to be
a pretty funny thing in the next like
year or so when all those phones that
came out last year with a headphone jack
that teased apple because oh we still
have a headphone jack and you don't when
all those come out in this next year and
don't have a headphone jack
i mean it's not like apple's gonna tease
back it's more of an i told you so but
yeah i'm definitely not looking forward
to that way it looks right now
pixel 2 probably won't have a headphone
jack
that's just the way it is have you
noticed in your videos that you move
your eyes on the camera monitor
sometimes
well yes
actually i have i'm actually impressed
that you have too a lot of times so the
the camera monitors right above
the camera obviously sometimes i'm just
like checking framing or making sure i'm
still in the middle i try not to look
away i'm trying to look here or maybe
i'll hold something up and i want to
make sure
it doesn't reflect too much so i'm
looking just to make sure it doesn't
like that that could happen but i don't
think it's it's too bad is it i try to
look at the camera mostly all right
we're good all right so i'm gonna end
this one uh chatter and i are gonna go
edit this video he actually edits like
everything now which is pretty awesome
so uh
talk to you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]
come on untie yourself you can do this
he's like
is he stupid
oh yeah you're the morning person
you're definitely oh she's going hard
around the neck hey
what are you doing you're the strongest
ones too
there you go
but that is definitely
tight now she's tightening my neck
that's weird give me that
i'm not a tree